joining me now from Manchester is the
former president of the European Society
for Pediatric infectious diseases
Professor Adam Finn Professor Finn good
to see you this afternoon
um three little ones have succumbed to
this in a week are you worried
well I I think this is an organism that
has been has not really attracted enough
attention up until now it's it's surging
back along with a lot of other
infections as the restrictions of the
pandemic come to an end but this uh this
particular bug has been causing invasive
disease in larger numbers actually the
meningococcus which is one that we're
all familiar with and we're against
which we have vaccines over a period of
many years and we see these bulges of
infection from time to time so it is a
bug that we ought to be focusing our
attention on more and I think we should
be developing a vaccine to try and
prevent it
now strep a uh very common tends to
present mildly people might not even
know they have it but it what these
children have died of is the invasive
variety of that um how does one become
the other and how do we know the
difference
yeah it's a good question this is a very
prevalent organism and invasive disease
occurs when it gets into the wrong place
essentially and starts to proliferate in
in the tissues or of the body where
bacteria wouldn't normally be it
normally sits in the throat and it can
cause trouble causing sore throats but
it doesn't get beyond that but once it
gets into the bloodstream or other parts
of the body it can really run rampant
and cause these very very serious cases
and there are particular strains of it
which seem to be more prone and more
able to do that which is why we do see
these outbreaks from time to time
of course parents are you know parents
fear the worst don't they they're
naturally worry about this
um should children with symptoms of this
even if it looks milder they should be
keeping them at home
uh well I think as with all infections
the parents do need to be the judge here
um children get fevers and infections
all the time particularly at this time
of year but when children begin to be
more unwell as you just heard Adriana
saying the fever is persistent they
develop a rash they're less responsive
not eating or staying ill for a longer
period That's the time to pick up the
phone uh get advice or take them to the
GP or to the local emergency department
for further evaluation these organisms
are very sensitive to penicillin
antibiotics so if the infection is
treated early it can often be brought
under control so a child that's sick and
not getting better over a period of time
that's the moment to seek further
attention
and you talked about antibiotics uh the
treatment you also talked earlier about
developing a vaccine
um how how long will that be in coming
uh it's not a vaccine that's in the
pipeline at the moment there are early
developmental candidates it's an
organism which in my opinion has been
much ignored over the years it doesn't
cause meningitis which is something that
has particularly accelerated attention
it does actually cause a lot of
moderatory and mortality around the
world it causes heart disease rheumatic
fever
glomerulonephritis which is a kidney
disease as well as these really bad
cases of invasive disease and something
called toxic shock syndrome so there are
many diseases this particular bug causes
and it's time we pulled our socks up and
really look for a way to prevent it and
what should schools be doing to try and
slow down the transmission
uh there's nothing much to schools can
do to slow the transmission uh at the
moment I mean of course that did happen
when schools were shut and children were
not contacting each other but uh you
know in normal times there's nothing
much that can be done where we see more
than one case occurring of invasive
disease in a school or an institution
then that's counted as an outbreak and
we do an investigation and often give
antibiotics to contacts but in the case
of a single case like this the
investigations are usually restricted to
very close home contacts that may be ill
and we don't otherwise
change Behavior or intervene with
antibiotics